Ja, der Four Ball in Versailles
Indies in Bratsche war für Ignorieren, Fühlen Sie sich
wichtig, in den nächsten Ballkörben war ungefähr in
New Hampshire, also ist mein nächstes
Gericht das Iowa-Reich, wenn wir ins Landesinnere fahren,
fehlt mir ein klares und letztes wie der
Deuter  Drazi Pass hier erwähnt einige
kommen auf Dane Canada das Kanada es
unterschwellig Präsidentschaftswellen während
der Demokratisierungsseite gibt es Martin
ulti republicano es ist allgemein
genug über Buster's am Ende
Republikaner Amador Erwachsene, die kommen, sie
tanzen Muster meines Kurses gingen hier über Schinken
weg für die nächste und gezielt
oder nicht ihr Ehrgeiz ein klares und Vivian
hier Meter Techniken der Tränen und Abba
Mohammed Gast hier namens Leine Kathie
Obradovich Z ist er ein Iowa Go Philly werden
in politischen Kolumnisten in
Grund von ihm Des Moines Register und a berichtet
Wer hat Einblick oder Degla, seit Artikel hier
in Iowa auf Z blieb ja und Netze arbeiteten
im Netzwerk, Nancy sagt, dass es eine
Nachrichtenredaktion gibt, die Bedoya die Belagerung
möglicherweise von einer kleineren Filiale hat  ts samgyetang
schade hier High Stars Capital versandt
abgeschafft nos Maschine und Schwindel Teton Dam
See unsere Nation Bundes Tartan gut für
Zoo kann untersuchen, ob im
höchsten Khandala auch Degnan zu vermeiden ist, sich
auf diese Schicht der irdischen
Shirdi-Regelpolitik zu konzentrieren, über die Kathy
noch gleich hier debattiert  in Des Moines Iowa in Iowa
in diesem Netzmagneten diese Suche englisch
hallo Kathy hallo schön dich hier zu haben
es ist mir eine Freude und Ehre danke dass du
mich hast das macht viel Spaß ich schätze
du bist also aufgeregt ich schätze ja es ist
sehr viel a  Caucus-Tag ist wie unser Super
Bowl, die Leute schauen sich den
Fußball an, den Super Bowl, den wir alle
gestern hatten, für politische Reporter,
das ist der Super Bowl in Iowa, das ist,
wer niemand war
Mit der Super-Bowl-Angstreporterin
ist dies selbst der Super-Bowl-Gast auf
Herz Kansas City Eins über Shawn
Malviya bekommt in der nächsten fiesen Anzeige
Kadaver von einem zivilen Ohana-Kollegen geschenkt
Und Samanas entweder die Schwester Netta
größer eines leitenden Produzenten als ein
Stammstudio in Washington würde ein Netz bei der
Invasion von Kohlenstoffemissionen um eine
Ölfarm einst weiße Beobachtungsdividende
hier Bush krachend kochen, den Trottel sehen
wir auf Suganya Nets
Defragmentierung hatten wir nicht  In Deutschland
tauchen Winkel auf vier sanfte Jahre alt wie
wir voller Ehrgeiz bündeln
Unannehmlichkeiten auf Runden Wenceslas ist
Minuten über Gewalt in Esther linear über
den Politiker, der hierher gekommen ist über Iowa
auf die Kadaver Abaddon von Abessinien
klar und die Swazi ein Hinweis auf Staat über
Techniker der Kadetten, wenn wir
im nächsten Vas sind und hier ma Kathy markieren,
vielleicht die erste Frage für Sie, wie
wichtig der Iowa Caucus ist, da er
der erste in der Reihe ist, aber Sie würden denken,
Iowa, warum ist das nicht so eine große Sache?
einer der bevölkerungsreichsten
Staaten der USA  Alle Kollegen haben mir
einmal gesagt, Iowa ist nicht wichtig, weil es das
erste ist, oder es tut mir leid, Iowa, es ist nicht das erste,
weil es wichtig ist, es ist wichtig,
weil es das erste ist, weil es die
erste tatsächliche Stimmabgabe im
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf 2020 ist, weil es die erste
Gelegenheit für die Wähler danach ist  all die
Umfragen und all das Gerede und all die
Kampagnen, um tatsächlich zu sagen, für wen sie
stimmen, und dieser Sieg hier in Iowa
hat den Kandidaten historisch gesehen die
Gelegenheit gegeben, Schwung in die
anderen frühen Staaten zu bringen, von denen viele Ihrer
Zuschauer vielleicht wissen  Primär in
New Hampshire baut es Schwung auf,
nach New Hampshire und den anderen inneren
Bundesstaaten zu kommen, und dann hoffentlich zur
Nominierung für sie, wenn Sie LeMond
hören, wie Bizet Smash Cafés Alpha DD
Flash-Englisch spielen, und ist so gut zum Bleiben, dass
er sich glücklicherweise fast identifiziert hat  Ich war ein
Fischgericht, als ich in Via Medians meine
Spirituosen von ala hier auf seine Tat war, war ich
offensichtlich in Bratsche, als
Statusanzeige dafür  Erzrebe dann
VASIMR hier war ich beruhigt Verhalten so wenig
auf der so Ana Art Schwung und Zustand, als
ich gehen werde Nam und shuanglin Ich
weiß, dass die unter dem Kandidaten im
mittleren Namen fertig sind und im nächsten und
für meinen im nächsten können  In seiner Praktikantin
in New Hampshire scheint
unser Verräter nicht zu verstehen, was
Amiata
in der nächsten Woche nicht und sie nicht Kathy
wissen, dass derzeit und hier viele demokratische
Kandidaten auf dem Stimmzettel stehen
für Zhu Honda
mio - Tim super gemein, wie wichtig
es ist, wenn du am Ende der Spitzenreiter
in Iowa bist, also bedeutet das nicht unbedingt, dass
du Präsident wirst, weißt du, wenn
Iowa nur der Erste ist, müssen wir noch
durch  In allen anderen Staaten bedeutet ein Sieg in
Iowa nicht automatisch, dass
jemand die Nominierung oder
die Präsidentschaft gewinnen wird, aber ich
würde Iowa tun, was es zuverlässig bewirkt, ist die
Anzahl der Kandidaten zu reduzieren, die wir mit
mehr als 25 Kandidaten gestartet haben
dieses Verfahren aus verschiedenen Gründen, einige von
ihnen konnten einfach kein Geld aufbringen, einige von
ihnen konnten nicht auf die Debattenbühne kommen,
sie sind ausgestiegen, mehr Kandidaten
werden nach heute aussteigen, weil sie
es nicht wirklich bis zum Starttor geschafft haben
und so  was ist was ich
mache wir tun Iowa schickt die
stärksten Kandidaten in den Rest des
Landes, da er Vegetation ist Iowa macht
Swasey als Füllkandidat und
ungeschult auf wir haben neue, aber eine
Sitzung für Gangnam yadi Ungarn in
besagtem noch seankervin  eifrig, aber er und ich
waren DDS. Ich beginne Sartre Cathy, den
Schalter, lehre die Unterzeichnung von Danan. Ich bin
nerful, ich habe sie gesehen, Sean, ich werde bein
gut glänzen  Nachrichtenteam und
super häufig, da kann ich Zustand ist
Vitamin, während ein Milizvisier Nichkhun
Yzerman ausgibt, zuversichtlich, dass ich komme, weil
das hier war, in Iowa passieren, hat keine
Sprache gewagt, ein Jahr gegeben Tora dde
Ereignis, seit du bist  Ich habe ein Melanin gefunden, das
automatisch von ihrem Kanada in zomom gemacht wurde. Die
Präsidentschaftskandidatin Suzanne
wird nicht fliegen, also Göttin Präsidentin. Ich bin
Superschurke Cathy
Mittagsshow in Deutschland und wir waren
gestern bei einigen der Veranstaltungen. Livan of
Vining hat unseren Jüngsten von
Elizabeth Warren vorgestellt. So ist der kanadische
Teenager Amethyst und Fauna in einer
Informationssitzung meines Designs durchgesickert und
von Pete Buddha Jet und Afton
Rice's Year gegeben  vor Burgermeister schuldet
Indiana gibt es eine Hoffman-Marke wäre
ein klares auf in einem von Einwanderern sprechenden
Kurs wir D-Caucuses-Englisch von SUNY
unter Shyamalan in ihrem Jahrgang gezeigt
und Charakterspaß I von
Basmatihüten und Dimension Baughman deutsch
-irischer Dämon kenne kaum Honk ooh
Sie schlussfolgerte, dass ein Flieger
Elizabeth Warren Louis Frish an Vikas durchgesickert hatte – das
Fehlen des ungesendeten Booms von Donald
Trumps Witz und Schloss DS ist der
Moment und Da  Ich bin ein Gamma-Sylveon, es ist
nicht mein eigenes Essen als Folie zu sehen, und als der
Moment geht, um Hak-su zu quälen, kam es aus
Amanas Tankentwicklung, es gewinnt, sie sind
optimistisch, dass Madonnas Kandidatin
Nvidia und ein Verkäufer im gemeinsamen Deck
von Donald Trump es tun  Seine kleine Chance
von Gossage sprach mit Jennifer und allen
kürzeren Streifen in einem Mafia-Kandidaten von
vor allem Elizabeth vom etre
berühmtesten Assistentenmuseum in Iowa und Abunda
begann mit dem Namen Fella Donald Trump Kebaya
Tom die Demo aus Baumwoll-Musselin-Handy leichter
Haus Koresh erregte keinen aufgehetzten Sitz
darüber hinaus Magnat erwähnte Eden, es ist
zusammenpassend, Towson Common besitzt ein Auto,
so dass Bürgermeister Pete Visa in Henan trägt
und sichert Harbin Country Budderball in
edlen Hören Monicas ODOT-Turnieren
Parata Burgermeister, der genau eine klare
Encana gut und ein Anti-Trumpf gibt, ein Samisen
über die Farbe von t  Huts Stiftungen ein
Designer Hoffman in einer Furlong King High
Rotten Sakura Ich hätte auch die Chance,
einen Ehering wie den zu tragen, den ich
bekommen habe  Auf meiner Hand gerade
Schönheit gh ist Homosexualität Gong vorne
Eisen auf Toyota Armeen auf Delegieren der
Dampf einladende Caucuses in Shul und
Cafés in Sparta und Athen Jeder Teil, den ich traf, führte
Charles an, Nenner,
ein Haufen Kanada, das Discutir auf Xenon gemacht hat, ist
kein verwundeter Rajesh Minuten lang  Body
Biber Bond für Zoo Honda unter einem, der
weiß, wer nancherla ein infiziertes
su sogar Kanada ensui schnüffelt, aber Anastacio als Tatsache ansah,
lange nachdem er Deacon a
Dartmouth Alaun Steamin und
Telefonmedizinfilm 15% im nächsten The
Wonder Core
genug für den eingedrungenen Rashmi Newton-Tag kannte  aber
bleib s t unvernünftig und ich bin denofa
bleedin und Kanadas Tante Liesl Conan geben
Haferbrei, jeder wurde ein berauschender Delegierter
und Dampf und Ayahuasca teilweise habe ich
ihm Zamans Gesicht mit Namen
und dem Biss eines Weinstocks in der nächsten
Kiste verwechselt  Kanada und Fair sind in diesem Jahr
ihr Bestand war groß genug
immobulus Manish schickte für mich, hängt
nur Scott OTT mannhaft an unserem
Etappenleiter ab und kann geben und sein  Sondern mag ansprechen,
wie wir jemals ein über Marshall na ja,
von Natur aus schmira klaffen t Hat und
Dimension Sugerman in einem Shounen
Vindicator
Iowa's Beyond laden einen Comiczeichner für die
Gesundheit ein Kathy Ich bin eine gute Seite einer Muslimin.
Dieses Unterfangen hat eine standardmäßige Anita
Zionistin zu einer Semiotikerin gemacht  ist da, aber Cathy
sieht sich an, wie es heute Abend funktioniert, also
kommen die Leute tatsächlich
in großer Zahl zu diesen Orten, wahrscheinlich dieses
Jahr mehr als in der Vergangenheit, warum die
Leute wirklich aufgeregt sind,
an diesem Präsidentschaftsrennen teilzunehmen, von dem Sie wissen, dass es einige
Jahre die Mieter gibt  Caucuses ist nicht
sehr hoch, im Moment liegt der Rekord bei
etwa 240.000 Menschen aus dem Jahr 2008,
als Barack Obama bei den Caucuses in Iowa war,
aber ein paar Dinge. Zunächst einmal gibt es
viele Kandidaten, und viele Kandidaten zu haben,
führt zu einer größeren Wahlbeteiligung, weil es
diese sind  Kandidaten und diese Kampagnen,
die die Menschen zur Teilnahme ermutigen,
und der zweite Grund ist, dass die
Demokraten einfach ein echtes Gefühl der
Dringlichkeit verspüren, daran teilnehmen zu wollen  aß und
wählte den richtigen Kandidaten aus, von dem sie
hoffen, dass er Donald Trump besiegen wird, da die
Handlung eines Cafés als natürliche Zoophilie
weit verbreitet ist Bazi-Zoophilie Kanada Nia ha ha
Ich kann Morgans zur Chanson-Armee
in Frankreich adaptieren Fela und auflegen Einladung
tat Wissenschaft befiehlt, in der ich beraten sollte  Ich
weiß, dass für diesen Verlust, der rostfreien
Amir verkauft, meine nicht für Gangnam für die
Gangnam-Mafia Yaron bei fünftausend
Gesetz an die Commons in eine vernünftige
Jolla zu tun ist, um sich auszurichten, indem ich weiß, dass diese
zerrissen sind, hallo oder die Feinde hinter
mir her sind  Fliegen haben tausend Nahrung genommen,
deshalb sind tausend gekommen, die Huzulen sind
Cathy, Herbst, es ist abgestimmt, die
Demokraten auf eine Tat, nicht verschwinden, Schnitt für
Stephen und gut in Kanada und Goethe,
Kanada in zu finden, warum diese Dringlichkeit auf
der demokratischen Seite ich denke, ein Teil davon
ist, dass sie einfach das Gefühl haben, dass das Land
unter Donald Trump in die falsche
Richtung geht. Sie wissen, dass es nicht wirklich
unbedingt um Amtsenthebung geht. Demokraten
wussten, wie sie über Amtsenthebung dachten
Bevor es eine einzige Anhörung in
Washington DC gab, denken sie, dass der Präsident
angeklagt werden sollte, aber Sie wissen, dass Sie sich Sorgen
um die Bürgerrechte machen, wie
diese Regierung mit der
Einwanderung umgeht, und ich denke, insbesondere
und vor allem andere Themen sind besorgt
über die Gesundheitsversorgung und die Regierung von Donald Trump
Bemühungen zur Demontage
des Affordable Care Act und dass ich denke, dass
dies ein Hauptanliegen ist, und wenn Sie die
Demokraten fragen, die Sie über wichtige Themen wissen,
wird jeder in meinem Alter oder älter sagen, dass die
jüngeren Wähler im Gesundheitswesen auch sehr
besorgt über College-Schulden sind und so  Das
ist auch ein großes Problem, denn das bringt
sie heraus, da das Diversity-Gesetz
diesen Krebs der
Verlegenheit erleichtert  Das
Sehen eines Freundes in der Tat ist es,
was eine eigene Gebührendimension ist / Morgen
tut Kathy Kazarka Saunders also Gesundheitssystem
war einer unter Obamacare First Aid
Affordable Care Act, da Augen auch mich
hinzufügen, der Reis ish Million und erwähnte
indische Wörter sind noch unterschreibender Arzt
passiert ein neues Klischee-Visier, aber oft
waren wir nicht Donald Trump erstaunt nach
so zwei drei,
so dass Victor Drano Besitzer war  Kong
Mediziner Knaus Ashton diskreter Ngons
Kosovo Brief von Kathy die Zahlen die
wir nächste Nacht bekommen werden es werden mehrere
Zahlen sein ich meine wir haben gerade gesehen wie das geht
das die Leute sich neu ausrichten können und
dann werden am Ende die Stimmen gezählt
und dann wissen wir es erst nicht  Aus der ersten
Ausrichtung, wie es heißt, wie viele
Personen
in der ersten Runde für eine Person gestimmt haben, erhalten wir auch
die Nummer der zweiten Runde, wenn
sie tatsächlich im Grunde neu gemischt haben,
und dann erhalten wir eine dritte Zahl, bei der es
darum geht, wie viele Delegierte eine Person erhält
wird, ist für
die Leute hier nicht so verwirrend, also war es früher so, dass
nur eine Nummer und das war die letzte
Nummer, die die Delegiertennummer veröffentlicht hat
s tun es anders
kritisiert, weil sie nicht transparent sind, und
es spitzte sich vor Jahren zu,
als Bernie Sanders und Hillary Clinton
in Iowa praktisch gleichauf waren. Bernie Sanders
hatte das Gefühl, dass seine Kampagne
tatsächlich mehr Leute hatte, aber man muss
die Leute haben  an den richtigen Stellen,
um Delegierte zu gewinnen, also ist es so,
als hätte Hillary Clinton die Volksabstimmung gewonnen,
aber Donald Trump hat die
Wahlen in den Vereinigten Staaten gewonnen. Dies
ist eine ähnliche Art von Setup, also der Grund,
den die Partei angibt  Diese
zusätzlichen Nummern herauszugeben ist, damit die Leute das
Gefühl haben, dass der Prozess transparent ist, und
sie können darauf vertrauen, dass ein
Vista zuhört, dass das seltsame richtige
Zeichen wird, dass sie zu nichts werden. Ja, das
wäre kein Pilz in ihrem Kopf, es ist AI
Atari my  System Betcha Kandidat in einem
Nicht-Kanada dann nach und es ist direkt
unter ihrem Hut Sulfat ist so unbekanntes
Kanada jung, aber Ihr Kandidat Hadiza
Lebensmittelimporte Eingang Anishka Schaft,
der einiges getan hat  Schloss vfat Ich werde
darauf bestehen, dass die Delegation von ihnen dampft,
nicht so Niall und es ist nicht so, dass keiner von
ihnen von ihnen Iowa-Teil wieder vergeblich angreift,
Boffin, so gut gemacht, dieser Dämon wird
nicht sterben, im Ruhestand, wir füllen eine Delegierte
Amanda M Zama durch  Das meiste zog
Emma Baumwolle an, die eingemauert wurde, und der
unter Kanada Zoll Tim, was ist das für ein Wunsch,
unsere ts zu verstecken – super gemeine,
gemeinste Nachrichten, die offen transparent sind, das ist
eine Weise, dass eine der Kanada und Sauvage
PS, die eine ist, oh gut, Akash Newton hatte
unsere  heißer Dampf sein fünfzig wichtiges Thema
welled vu Hinson wurde Idzik DS ein
[ __ ] verdient eine größere Gangabwasser in
Kanada seit Aggressor Cathy einundvierzig
Stimmen oder Delegierte, das ist die Zahl
plus einige zusätzliche Delegierte, die
von der Democratic National Party und
so weiter oder aus Iowa kommen  Partei diese
einundvierzig plus neun eigentlich andere Delegierte,
die im Sommer während des Democratic
National Convention dann zu einem
der Kandidaten gehen können, wie einundvierzig keine
große Zahl im Vergleich zu Te ist  xas Florida
Kalifornien,
wie viel Einfluss kann das
haben,
wahrscheinlich bis Sie zum
Nationalkonvent kommen, nicht sehr viel,
weil Iowa wie viele andere Staaten
alle seine Delegiertenstimmen für
den erwarteten Kandidaten abgeben wird, und das passiert  Es
passiert viel, aber die
wirklich wichtige Zahl
für Kandidaten ist oft nicht unbedingt, wie
viele Delegierte sie aus dem
Prozess herausholen, sondern nur, wo sie im
Feld abschließen. Sie möchten also wirklich
diese Dynamik aufbauen, um in andere Staaten zu gehen
Sie können der Kandidat sein Iowa ist ein
Ort, an dem dies kostengünstiger ist
und an dem Sie viel kostenlose Medienaufmerksamkeit erhalten können.
Daher ist Iowa ein guter
Ausgangspunkt für diese Kandidaten, auch
wenn die 41 Delegierten es am Ende
nicht sind  wird der große Preis sein
Vista schob ein süßes Zuhause Ich
delegiere nicht und Holz Knutson und
Kartoffelspiele OMA-Bürger Iowa der Camión für
su namenlose de hat ihre
effiziente Demokratische Partei weder ein- noch ausgeschaltet
Kationen und Hüte auch Tata hat er irgendwie
mitgekämpft - das Kadaverspiel, was das
natürlich ist
Ich würde sie wieder verklagen
Diese Dampf-Invalides in Kanada, was das
für jedes Gericht ist, sogar die Spartaner Sean
und Susan - nicht so gut haften, tut ein
paar Lügen Tür versteckte X-Infoleiste am besten
Versicherung nicht, und wir wollen einen Blick
auf die neuesten Zahlen von vor ein paar
Tagen werfen. Vor zwei Tagen kamen NBC News und das
Wall Street Journal mit diesen
Zahlen hier, das sind die Zahlen auf
nationaler Ebene, die nur für Sushil verwendet werden
Wir sind hier Design oder Verkauf bei
Syntagma NBC News Wall Street Journal
Was frisst es Schild nicht bald unsere Nische
nach Iowa beschäftigt und als Bernie Sanders Smith
Zeeman sponsert % Dinah's einen lustigen Hut  für
Joe Biden Dan Elizabeth Warren Jean und
sie schneiden Cash Loggin
Bloomberg sie sind hier Ganesha üben
sie kommen zum SPM Super Tuesday
in Boston in Mathe Insulin auf Pete Körper
jij sie sind Burger meine Stars Indiana Don
von Amy Klobuchar und Andrew Young  Was
halten Sie von diesen Zahlen? Cathy, so
landesweit und in Iowa Joe Biden und
Bernie Sanders haben die Umfragen
der Iowa-Caucus-Besucher angeführt.
Elizabeth Warren war auch in vielen Ayat-Umfragen von Iowa unter den
ersten drei oder ersten vier Kandidaten
Caucus-Besucher und da
beginnen sich die Dinge zu ändern.
Michael Bloomberg tritt nicht bei
den Iowa-Caucuses an, für die er
hier nicht gekämpft hat. Ich erwarte, dass er
im Rudel P boo sehr niedrig abschließen wird, um zu beurteilen, auf
der anderen Seite ist es und auch Amy
Klobuchar  haben
viel Zeit in Iowa verbracht, haben
hier gute Wahlkampforganisationen aufgebaut und sie haben
nicht nur höhere Umfragewerte in Iowa, sondern
sie sind beide in einer Position, in
der sie die übertreffen könnten  Ir-
Umfragezahlen Ich werde sagen, Sie wissen, dass wir in Iowa den
nationalen Umfragen nicht so viel Aufmerksamkeit schenken,
die viele Leute anziehen, wo
die Kampagnen einfach nicht stattfinden,
dort achten sie oft nicht darauf, was
sie tun.  Ich weiß nicht einmal, wer viele
dieser Leute sind, und deshalb ziehe ich es vor, selbst bei den
Parlamentswahlen, wenn wir
hier in Iowa Nominierte haben, auf die Schlachtfeldstaaten zu schauen, auf
die Staaten
wie Iowa, Michigan, Pennsylvania, und
auf diese Tage im Gegensatz zu den
Nationales Bild als Kalb wirkt im
Gegensatz zu Onos Bösartigkeit Indian Varlyn
im November Niedergang und Start in
Dänisch lock em con in einem Team von Seaford
und in Republicano Donald Trump Befehl
für die demokratischen Frauen unter weich ist nicht
eher gab ich der NASA einen Homonym auf
Auch eine Nebelversicherung, die mit ihnen zusammenarbeitete, war
hier in Iowa Verluste von Schmitz klügeres
bewusstes Design, so dass Bernie
Sanders sich für einen undichten
Flug verschworen hatte, Elizabeth Warrens Blitz hakte
Amy Klobuchar den Oz Minneso ab  ta beruhigt, wie
trübe ein Visier Leck Missachtung ähnlich wie
ID Fauna auf die Erwähnung von Iowa und eine
Wiedergutmachung in einem nicht so 9-Ball-
Glanz von Diven aus der Gnade noch der
in Mais von Jesaja Handel in Middlebury geschehen war, lasst uns
über meinen Ausschuss abstimmen  Ich
weiß, dass die Onondaga im Squash-Squash weit
oben steht und Valecia eine
Lisette war vertraut, Alice ed war eine Nazi-
Zombies, die nicht nachließ, bevor sie zum
Telefonieren auf und souchong beruhigte
Cathy, es ist immer eine Frage,
jetzt ist die Frage der Wählbarkeit und
Die Frage, lassen Sie mich nur sehen, ob ich
die Zahlen hier wählbar finde, und
die Frage, ob Sie auf
der Grundlage von Themen abstimmen sollten, und ob wir uns
diese Tabelle hier ansehen, die auch
Street Journal und NBC Zen Bahia de Sol
und weniger Dania waren  Elegant Kanada waren wir
da oder Papa keine Option Ich habe nicht im
Nebellicht so Donald Trump durch die nicht
bald und während im November in Via
Biden Agnes eine Dame tut - in Biden Sanders
warnte Körperrichter Burton andere für
Donald Trump  Ling, was
sagt uns diese Tabelle, Kathy,
also zuallererst denke ich, dass dies ein
sehr frühes Bild dieser Matchups ist. Ich
denke, dass sich das Bild ändert, wenn
es einen tatsächlichen Kandidaten gibt und die Leute
wissen, wer diese Person ist, und
sie direkt gegen sie abwägen  Donald Trump Ich
denke, das sagt mir, dass die Wähler
im ganzen Land offen dafür sind, einen
anderen Kandidaten als
Donald Trump in Betracht zu ziehen, und Sie sind nicht unbedingt,
dass er verlieren wird, also
ist die Wählbarkeit eine lustige Sache, die Leute
haben unterschiedliche Vorstellungen davon, welche Art von
Kandidat  in Iowa wählbar ist,
führen wir alle vier Jahre ein Gespräch
darüber, ob progressive Kandidaten, die
einen großen Kontrast zum
republikanischen Kandidaten darstellen, der beste Weg sind, um
einen Amtsinhaber zu schlagen, oder ob Sie versuchen,
jemanden zu nominieren, der gemäßigter ist
und ansprechen kann  Wähler in der Mitte
Letztendlich ist meine persönliche Meinung ein
Kandidat, der wählbar ist, sobald er
gewählt ist, wie bei uns
s ein Englisch wie
Vista, das ist ganz Kanada und D von Idioten
entlarven seine eigene gemeinsame Bahia,
die Bernie Sanders oder Elizabeth Warren, die
einen befreundeten Gesandten in der
Ära der ersten Revolution führen, und oder in der Nähe von Deutsch Sean
Royal, das ist der n-dimensionale
Gerichtsvollzieher des HABM in Kenntnis Coverity Aaron
Cohen  Ein Mann mit Tränen in den Augen des
Moderators von heute ist, wenn er
über die englische Gesellschaft hört. Die Initialen des Demokraten in
Kanada sind Donald Trump Sushil
auf dem höchsten Akka. Ich denke, Kanada ist kein sehr
starker Kandidat, weil
jeder in der Lage wäre,
Donald Trump tatsächlich zu schlagen  Im Moment ist dies nur
eine Momentaufnahme. Ja, im Moment
wissen Sie, dass wir über
diese nationalen Umfragen sprechen müssen. Sie ziehen eine
Menge Leute an, die wirklich nicht
aufpassen und vielleicht nicht einmal sicher wissen,
wer diese Leute sind  Wissen Sie zu
diesem Zeitpunkt nur, dass sie für jemand
anderen als Donald Trump offen sind, und Sie
wissen für einen amtierenden Präsidenten, der
ihn ein wenig beunruhigen sollte, da Nvidia ein
gültiges Signal hat  Hat uns oft hierher gebracht, nach
Dimension von Rechten im Meer von Menschen,
unter Zeichen verklagen Larson, es ist Donald Trump,
der Soldat Donald Trump, Agnes, verklage
Dengue-Geist, Kathy, wenn du
Anita und ihren Franklin gebraten hast, hat sogar ein paar
Inselöffnungen gemacht, die ich kenne und in Kanada
indossiert  Auf der anderen Seite tun wir
dem Klobuchar Mitch 2tg Top-Versuch
Cayman weh, wir könnten HD Pharma scheitern, indem
jemand darauf hinwies, dass er Pete
Buddha mag, der ihn mit John F.
Kennedy vergleicht, nur ein bisschen ein
jüngerer Kandidat, aber die Frage, dass
jemand  Es wurde gefragt, ob sie sich hier
für Bernie Sanders
oder Elizabeth Warren entscheiden und nicht für die
gemäßigteren Kandidaten, wenn die gemäßigten
Kandidaten es hier schwer haben, stellt
das eine Bedrohung für die Demokratische
Partei dar, weil es schwieriger sein wird,
Donald Trump zu schlagen, denkst du  das geht
auf meinen Kommentar zurück, wie Leute auf
der progressiven Seite denken, dass nur ein
progressiver Kandidat gewinnen kann, und Leute
auf der moderateren Seite denken
das nur
Sie wissen, dass gemäßigtere Kandidaten gewinnen können. Ich denke, die größte
Gefahr für die Demokratische Partei besteht darin, wenn sie sich
nicht wie vor vier Jahren
hinter den Kandidaten stellen. Es gab
viele Leute, die für einen der
Kandidaten in den Vorwahlen waren  nicht,
sie mochten Hillary Clinton nicht, sie
haben sie nicht gewählt, und so
etwas ist es, was
für die Demokratische Partei im
November ein echtes Problem darstellt, wenn sie die Leute nicht dazu bringen kann, sich zu
outen. Ich ging zu a  Wahllokal am
Wahltag vor vier Jahren, und da
war ein 18-jähriger junger Mann, der
bei seiner allerersten Präsidentschaftswahl abstimmte,
und ich fragte ihn, wen er wählte, und
er sagte, ich habe wegen meines Kandidaten nicht an der
Präsidentschaftswahl teilgenommen
lief nicht und der
jüngste Vater stand einfach hinter
ihm und ging, weißt du, ich sehe kein als de
moda Rodney so gute Option Ich habe nicht gehört, dass
Dan gegen No Dan die Demokratische Partei
betreff Nora a Shannon Ben's Eastern
sogar ish
a la  Vella  angedeutet in hora de calidad in
Sharan kannte mich gar nicht als
MMA Netzwerk vor allem wenn Bernie Sanders um
Elizabeth Warren nominiert und Muslime
und Ervin um Dyskinesie Shan Xue Zhang
Jie für Joe Biden oder Gates Guy überlebte
breitester Kandidat Sufi Ehrlichkeit Demokrat
und und  Böse für Leland Moomba Cadogan
Azov und Joe Biden Nominierte Atwater und
Bernie Sanders so offensichtliche Pamphlete
Mullally spielte Klempner Anand und
Begrenzer nicht yulish Diamondback Fond
Dame Canada die Engländerin von der Rolle, die ich
Welt dominiere, wir hatten auch die Frage,
was wäre oder wer wäre dein
Favorit Ich befürworte jemanden ja nein Ich
befürworte nicht Ich
habe noch nie Ich habe noch nie befürwortet Obwohl
ich das Des Moines Register verlassen habe, bevor
sie einen Kandidaten unterstützt haben, war ich also nie
persönlich an der Unterstützung eines
Präsidentschaftskandidaten beteiligt, weil ich
Nachrichten schreibe  Neben Kommentaren auf unserer
Website ist es besser für mich, neutral zu sein,
und ich habe nie gesagt, dass
ich politisch unabhängig bin, also
denke ich, dass ich  Es ist besser, in der Lage zu sein,
unparteiisch zu sein, da mit Cafés aktiv geborene
Potage mehr Naman-Ordnungsanzüge in
Englisch gespielt werden, die Unterdrückten ihn in Kanada sterben,
noch irgendein Kandidat im Sium und das
N-Wort Ich war Aoife Zurückhaltung Nation nur
eine rosafarbene Flut lud ein  höherer
Name vor Jungfernhäutchen okay ah saudischer Nebel ein Café
werden sie die Versammlungen tatsächlich
im Fernsehen übertragen können Sie es tatsächlich
live sehen oder ist es geheim, was passiert ist, also
ist es nicht geheim, aber ich kann nicht ich
weiß nicht, ob jede Versammlung übertragen wird
Live wird es bei nationalen und
internationalen Nachrichtenagenturen bei Versammlungen im
ganzen Bundesstaat geben, und sie können sehr
gut übertragen, was bei
dieser Versammlung passiert, wenn die Ergebnisse
bekannt gegeben werden. Ich würde erwarten, dass es
eine Menge Live-Berichterstattung darüber geben wird
Nun, ich habe
über 30 Jahre Erfahrung mit der Berichterstattung über den Kaukasus-Burr gemacht, dass
jeder, der zuschauen möchte, hineingehen
und zuschauen kann. Sie müssen sich nicht anmelden.
Sie müssen kein Medienausweis sein.
Sie k  Jetzt so zu tun,
dass Sie jeder hineingehen und
beobachten können, wie Felicia fertig ist, sind
transparente Dirac und Hindi und der
Konsum von Allison-Fans und Kriegsdreieck
Hank-Naturalismus oft in geringem Geld, das
auf Bestellung ist, einen mittleren v1-Swashb zu finanzieren, es ist
klüger, sogar DS  Affären sind lang und
geheimnisvolle Spielbequemlichkeit in der nächsten
Messerbürste mit Pfizer und in einem verspotteten
Zeichen und Zielantrieb für Sheena Caucuses
in Ich weiß, geht in Anamosa Halawa in Ich bin ein
guter Junge - Todd Finnlands Bürgermeister einer
High-End-Verbindung wie in so Fairness
Alice aus der Wissenschaft
aller Verse und Einstein kommen für Hannahs
Grenze Valen Valen die gewöhnlichen Muslime
Eve waren Arme, die von New adidas entworfen wurden, um
Dutzenden von D-Hubs nach Suresh Dan
Mitsu Shimon als partielle Asana für Hans
im Schnatz über einem Schredder auszuweichen  kommen zu einem
team waren die daphne schmear MIT van Ich habe
nur darauf hingewiesen, dass wer nach
sieben kommt und mitmachen will, zu
spät ist, also ist die Tür für sie geschlossen,
aber sie könnten immer noch zuschauen  Wenn sie
wollen, können sie einfach nicht mit den anderen abstimmen.
Ja, und ich denke, dass die Leute
beobachten möchten, dass sie vor
7:00 Uhr auftauchen, ist eine gute Idee.
Dies werden sehr überfüllte
Versammlungsorte sein, und so ist das Parken manchmal
das  ist das Problem, das Sie wissen, dass Sie
nicht einsteigen möchten, weil Sie einen Parkplatz finden können,
absolut fertig, sagen wir, Sie und
Gus Fuchsia brauchten Rosen, entschieden, alle
strittigen Rechte.
Ich war auf der Flagge,
auch geplant, um Bloomberg
Degas Fluggeschwindigkeit zu besuchen. Englische Dicke in dieser
Spanne von Karen Powell von YouTube Flagge
ist eine hinterhältige und ehrliche, künstlerische ish
Natürlich ist er
hier während der Wahlvorstände nicht auf dem Stimmzettel, also ist es
strategisch, dass für ihn, dass er
nicht hier und in New Hampshire ist, der Weg, um die Nominierung zu
gewinnen, historisch gesehen der Weg war, um die Nominierung zu gewinnen
Kandidaten, die Iowa überspringen,
überspringen New Hampshire, überspringen die frühen Bundesstaaten durch den gesamten
Prozess, enden damit, dass der Prozess einfach an ihnen
vorbeigeht
Sie verpassen eine Gelegenheit,
ihre Botschaft zu testen, um herauszufinden, dass Sie
wissen, wie Sie am besten mit Wählern in Kontakt treten, von denen
Sie wissen, dass das Schalten von Fernsehwerbung nicht
der Weg ist, um die Wahlen in Iowa zu gewinnen, und Sie
wissen, dass dies in vielen Staaten der Fall ist  Ich
werde das auch nicht gut aufnehmen. Sie
können die Nominierung nicht einfach mit Fernsehwerbung kaufen,
da ein Michael Bloomberg in ihrer
Top-Mushiya ist. Er besaß einen Scan und schoss
erneut, nachdem Kathy geschädigt wurde
Wieder Entfremdung und die grellen Höhen,
die Norman und die Würze von Biden
Valen testen und jetzt töricht werden, fair, aber ein
Natsuna und abscheulich und das Blatt eingeben. Mahan
Michael Bloomberg ist eine dänische Möse, die
auf Jupiter zum Bügeln wartet  und ein
Sportereignis ein Super Bowl bei ihnen ein
Neun-Minuten-gegen-Pot-Cash Ich
schwafele nicht Arztmeister bei Auftritten Donald
Trump, er wirft eine Menge Geld auf das, was
er jetzt in der Kampagne tut, wird
ihm das wirklich helfen oder werden die Leute
sagen  Nun, er versucht, die Wahlen gut zu erkaufen.
Ich denke, das wird ihm helfen, seinen Bekanntheitsgrad zu steigern. Ich denke, das
ist der beste Weg, Fernsehwerbung zu verwenden,
damit die Leute wissen,
wer du hast, aber an Orten wie
Iowa sehen die Leute das mit Argwohn, und
du bist es  um es zu erreichen, wird nicht einmal sehr kluges
Geld ausgegeben, weil Sie
eine Menge Leute erreichen, die nicht
zu den Versammlungen gehen werden, also
historisch gesehen Kandidaten, die gerade
versucht haben, viele Anzeigen zu kaufen, hier nicht gut abschneiden,
und Sie wissen, wenn  er wird nicht
gut abschneiden hier in den Caucuses er wird nicht
gut abschneiden hier in den Parlamentswahlen,
wenn Iowa sehr wohl ein Schlachtfeld sein kann
Staatscafés Actus spülen
türkischen Tee und Matzo-Blob-Kollegen tut es,
wenn Zook hier ist, um schicke Sportalliterati zu kaufen
Auf einem auffälligen auf HD die neuen
Gebäude defundieren und die Übersetzung
ist er Bauch im Anhang, nicht wenn der
Naturforscher auch überspringt - Nebel und Kathy Aqua
werden nicht erwähnt, nachdem für
Zeus geschlussfolgert wurde, was das Vertrauen teilt
Wasserstoff kein Condor, also lass uns vorbeikommen
Die in der Tat swashb Elizabeth Warren, um
Bernie Sanders zu verstehen, Cindy
sooo, die Partituren wieder zu bekommen, Gagan, also zu
etablieren, oder unser König, auch wiederum,
em auf sowjetische Argumente, sogar zu uns von
diesen in Velen gekommen, nett, oh gut, und ich
war unter Hi Manuel Amaya  von Ihnen, um
alle Streitigkeiten zu ebnen, holen Sie sich jemanden, der
weiß, dass es dieses Jahr ist. Ich werde Ihnen vergeben,
vergessen Sie die Idee, dass Candy Dad eine Art
Spott darüber war, kommen Sie am Horizont vor mir. Ich
habe Make-up auf dem Feld
Von den
großen Fragen, welche Rolle
spielt das große Geld, weil Sie so viel
Geld brauchen, auch wenn Sie nicht Michael
Bloomberg sind, wenn Sie einer der anderen
Kandidaten sind, für die Sie so viel Geld ausgeben  Die
ganze Operation ist
sehr teuer, plus die Fernsehwerbung, welche
Rolle spielt sie,
also spielt Geld in Iowa weniger eine Rolle
als in der nationalen Kampagne.
Geld hat eine Rolle gespielt, wenn es darum geht, dass die
Kandidaten einen bestimmten Geldbetrag aufbringen müssen
von einer bestimmten Anzahl von
Spendern, um auf die Debattenbühne zu kommen, also
macht das einen großen Unterschied,
Geld für Werbung zu haben, hilft den
Kandidaten, ihre Namensidentität zu erhöhen,
und hey, Sie wollen
etwas Geld für Werbung haben. Iowa ist
der Staat, in dem die Werbung nicht funktioniert.  Es
kostet nicht ganz so viel und der wirklich
große Teil des Wahlkampfs und des
guten Abschneidens in Iowa besteht darin, eine großartige
Basiskampagne zu haben, bei der Sie
als
Kandidat und Ihre Unterstützer direkt mit den Wählern sprechen und
ihre Freunde, ihre
Familienmitglieder und ihre Nachbarn überzeugen  sich
freiwillig zu melden und zu telefonieren und
sie alle dazu zu bringen, zu den Versammlungen zu gehen, und
dieser Teil der Operation ist ehrlich gesagt
nicht sehr teuer und das ist das
Effektivste  ktive Sache, die ein Kandidat in Ordnung machen könnte,
Octus Vida in den Sand, was dann dazu
führt, dass Pete Nevada oft bei su-9
und sogar einem Naturforscher HD-
Fans unseres Sports natürlich weich macht, die
Hirschaugen in der Tat besonders Insulin calidad
Marsianer meistens Muslime und klar, dass er
hier nicht ist  inland risin unser das war ich stimme zu
sagte durch anständigen wein ist V filament
war im cafe auf stars Zinta von dan von
zwei anzügen gegen ooh klinger auf
deloitte safra grüns berührte sogar seine
erzwingen es geht darum, die c-d-i
notre dame zu säen und auf kanada und ein irisch
Timmy Spiel, wenn nicht fünf Alligator
nicht erwähnt D versteckt auf freiwilliger
Basis Frauen seine Tätigkeit als Bratendorf
Midheaven die andere Seite investiert Aal und
iam telefoniert, es ist keine Monoflosse für die
Gesellschaft, die sie tut, was Zeit braucht und
dadurch was ist  sie nennen Ishmael
Karte auch Söhne von Abu Barton in
Washington Suzanne Mann's jeder auf unzoom
Andy hier in Denver kann endlich
ihrem Muslim das MIT-Manöver geben hüpfte auf
eine Sean's Hut eine Mäanderbrücke  ed web app
ja der Biss Susan, als die Harmony
mir über Kanada gezeigt hatte oder sie lebte in der
Lektion eins Cory Booker Körbe weise auf
Essen unter dem ist nicht unser Stall ein
Oscar Schweden Visier Nichkhun erweitern
werden Horizont ish Megan okay Tom Oh
Ellen Barkin  Kämpfer für so Jetson Angus,
es ist da oder neue Bomber, die Dampf
und ganze Damen darin haben - auf
Froschmoment unversehrter
Phil Ich bin über die Ferne gestolpert, um einen
Techniker auf Vivia Abidin in
Leinwand zu bringen - okay, vielen Dank,
ich werde es versuchen  Um diese Frage zu beantworten,
denn wenn Sie die Ergebnisse erhalten und
ich ein wenig über unser Setup sprechen kann,
habe ich eine Frage an Sie,
ebenso wie ich über Dominanz. Trifft
dies auf genügend Lack, um benutzerdefinierte
Filter zu erstellen, ist dieser hier außerhalb der Website  das ist,
wo ein zebu unter draußen auf der
kugel getan fühlt sich an wie sean holmes sogar
würdig ich gab mir ein paar erledigte s
schön zu wissen das ist warum donna so hoch wie
diese weiß was für geräusche draußen mönche
warum anoxie oft durch den verschwitzen  Ich gab
Mrs.  oder harmloser Mann, wenn sie
glücklich sind, NASA für Nicht-Schwanen, jeder neu auf
Oktan-Einstein-Hörnern auf unserem Mazda-
Nebelgerät, und doch werden sie in der
D-Liga-Instrument auf mm untergehen, hier ist Iowa
gegen fertiges Angeln, das Geschäft hatte, das
über einen Knopfblitz Amiens gesendet hatte  Mutter
und Kalb, eine kleine Schwester, reichen ein Bahama-
Off über Indien ein
Rahm ist Partner bei NBC Ich zitiere meinen
Zustand, schicke Zenda, wenn diese
eine hella tyldus tisha-Statuswunden mögen,
sind Reifen, die die höchsten Bahama-
Täler von Schneider Platzer der
Begründung sind  die lincolns hab ich gesehen das wir
kein alibi hatten versuch einen fisch als wir
deepavali ausgewertet haben sag er wiederum wirkt
schnell abidin vers und füll dich in
höhe als andaman oder neun oder krieg
deine kosmetik
markt szene nicht ausweichen krieg ist da Martin
parallel über Schinken hier und testet seine
Wertschätzung beim NB ein Hündchenmaterial für
Nonnen Urban Parkland von NBC auf von
unter als der als
Fernserver hier zu werden, meine Güte von Hudson entscheidet, dass wir
nicht vorbeikommen können  Dan Schneider Zöpfe nicht
de niñas Trumps aus stehlen setzt den
Korrespondenten, den er Washington kennt, wenn
jeder keiner der unter Hände ich
Zugang eines genialen Technikers
beißt, wie ein Faff Tegan Kernan hätten wir
natürlich Kameramann Meter von
der Schwester Petaluma der Peterbilt in einem glänzen  Die
nächste Hommage von Nath Sue Steffi an
unsere Produzentin in Utah, unterzeichnet von den
Caucuses mit Ian und I'm Austin, wird
ein Spiegel einer spreizenden hellen Seite sein,
wenn Conan plant, eine Emo-Meile von Joe Biden zu bestellen, um
von Bernie Sanders vorbei  Ihre Party die
NAFTA beißt Susan, das ist ein bisschen Material,
ohne dass er ein Gababa ist, also beißt er ein Jahr lang
Reggaeton
wäre das Endergebnis in New
Hampshire, dass Harmon von der Leine verschwindet, aber
in einem Teil, den ich für den Zoo markiert habe, kann ich einen
Live-Stream sehen, die Herren verklagen Martin, obwohl er
Schwimmübungen analysiert hat und ein Typ Wunde bietet
in den nächsten Nüssen Omaha draußen ist es
Moses Quarz Overlay Genom 15 waren bei
weitem wie ein unser Team greift das Magazin
selbst an 1vd Ich gab nosov Enzo analysierte
Träume Ich weiß ein mein Liebling oder umgekehrt
Koffein kein Hi Bition Fragonard Botschaft
Schuldenseite muss sein Ich bin nicht  Also ich meine, ich
würde nicht in Kathy verraten, dass Sie
natürlich für den
Kapitalversandteil dieses Netzwerks von
hauptsächlich Online-Verkaufsstellen arbeiten, die tatsächlich
versuchen, über Politik zu
politischen Themen zu berichten, Recherchearbeit,
warum ist das in der amerikanischen Zeitung so notwendig  Die
Industrie hat
einige ernsthafte Herausforderungen durchgemacht, wirklich
jahrzehntelange Herausforderungen im Zusammenhang mit der
Tatsache, dass das Internet wirklich
die Quelle für Nachrichten übernimmt
und jüngere Leute Zeitungen einfach nicht
mehr nehmen. Zeitungen wie mein
ehemaliger Arbeitgeber digitalisieren dort
sie  stellen ihr Produkt online,
sind aber abhängig von
Werbeeinnahmen und Werbung, die sie
für ihr Online-Produkt online verkaufen können  Es
bringt nicht annähernd so viel
Umsatz wie die
Zeitung, die physische
Papierzeitung bringt, also haben Sie eine schwierige
Einnahmesituation, und Sie haben auch
viele Zeitungen, die Teil von jetzt
börsennotierten Unternehmen sind  Die
Aktionäre dieser Unternehmen haben
gewisse Rentabilitätserwartungen,
und so haben wir viele Zeitungen gesehen, die
Jahr für Jahr Mitarbeiter entlassen haben,
auch das UM im Nebel
und vernichtet unser Café, das den gleichen
Füllertitel besitzt und auf Schwedisch Karte wird
und teilweise aufgetaucht Ivan der Laser-
Gouverneur erhöht Problem und nicht schädlich
von einem Jahr in Formaten eigene digitale
verheiratete Sytem Liaison gleitet
8ish die Firma und es ist aufregend,
wenn Besuche in einem College von Café-
Türmen auf einem Nigga-Z-Double-Feed
werden  zu Essig voyons ist eine
Scheibe und es gibt auch Tränen des Analytikers Angus
darin und irrational die Satsuki-
Fehde, die ich für Gangnam Yashamaru-
Müll für uns in einer Lektion meine  gesehen garn
tausend sind nicht nach draußen zu schauen, wenn er
und es war ein gericht schemata
una vermögen der seismo-monitor sagen
farmville livadas war in am bundestag
aura in einem rucola in alaun lanka
verluste als esther css dorffrauen
abend bürgermeisterin freizeitjournalistin
frech hund eisprung  Im Café Marxismus
ist es Netzwerk, Netzwerk, staatliche Nachrichtenredaktion, also
sehe ich hohe Sterne, ist der Kapitalversand
und in teuflischen Top-Sponsoren verwundete Sterne
in Schismen unter dem Gutschein Online-
Verkaufsstellen mit Journalisten in Mitte durch das
Arztziel, die Wunschverhandlung, an der unsere
Klage Graham nicht teilnehmen wird  Sushil on on lace on
sweat sagte Cathy, vielen Dank, dass Sie
hier bei uns sind.
Ich verstehe, dass Sie nächste Nacht
die Nacht damit verbringen werden, die
Ergebnisse auf einem der lokalen Sender
hier zu kommentieren, ja, und zwischendurch an der Bearbeitung zu arbeiten,
ok, also machen wir  den gleichen Job
und versuchen, die Öffentlichkeit über
Fuzzy-Wuzzy Allison von dort zu informieren, und wir
mögen es immer, wenn sich die Leute für das
interessieren, was wir tun, weil es
wichtig ist  Ich schätze für die Entscheidungen, die sie
nicht nur jetzt, sondern im
November hier in den USA unbedingt treffen müssen, und
vielen Dank dafür, dass ich so
froh bin zu sehen, dass Sie hier
bereits über dieses Thema berichten und
auch Journalisten  aus der ganzen Welt,
also danke, dass du auch hier bist. Danke,
Cathy, danke, schon, Anita von
Philly, Fagin, lieber Benutzer, Leonard, den du
auf Sushil und Sushil gesehen hast, dann haben wir vier
Nicht-Null-EDA per Bond, bevor wir
mit dem nächsten Live-Stream sogar fertig sind
Gedanken nach innen dean-starkes Deutsch nach
außen und vergrößernd Suba und oft
neue Körper Ich gab Nnessee hier, um dunkel zu sein,
was betrifft, wenn Sie Shawns
Erfindung aus dem Motor bewaffnet verklagen